- Hello.
(both speaking in foreign language)
- Hi, I'm Alana and I'm here with Josh,
who plays Prince Charles in "The Crown".
And we're gonna talk a
little bit about Welsh today.
(classical music)
So, obviously your
character, Prince Charles.
- Yep.
- Had to learn Welsh.
We are now going to test your Welsh.
I'm just gonna show you.
- Okay.
- A card with Welsh on it.
- And what we need you to do
is to try and pronounce it
and then tell us what it means.
- This is gonna be a disaster.
- No, it's gonna be great.
You're gonna do so well.
(soft pop music)
(speaking foreign language)
- Oh, that's not bad.
It's actually (speaking foreign language).
- What do you think it
means? (Josh speaks in Welsh)
- What's your name?
- No, it's more like, how,
It's like hello, how are you?
In one.
- Hello, (speaks in Welsh)
- Okay.
(Speaks in Welsh)
It's like how are you.
- Yes!
- Yeah.
- Ding, ding, ding.
- Knew that one.
Yes.
Speaks in Welsh
- Yeah.
- It means something,
something out like Gavin
and Stacey, isn't it?
(Speaks in Welsh)
A hug?
- Yeah, it is!
- Is it?
- It is!
- Yes.
I think I actually use
that in my day-to-day life.
- (speaks in Welsh) it's about a word
than hug in my opinion.
(soft pop music)
(Josh speaks in Welsh).
- It's (speaks in Welsh).
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
- Cheers.
- Yeah!
(Josh snaps his fingers)
- I did not know now how
that's, how you spell it.
- That's how you spell it.
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
(Alana laughs)
- Great, there you go.
I did half a job on that one.
(soft pop music)
- This one is mean.
- Okay, that's the
train station, isn't it?
(Alana laughs)
Oh no! Okay. I'm gonna just try it
and I'm sorry to anyone,
any resident of this place.
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
(Alana chuckles)
- That was incredible.
- Can you do it?
- Yeah, I can.
- Go on.
(Alana speaks in Welsh)
Yeah, basically the same.
- So you nailed it.
- Basically the same.
- You nailed it.
- Yeah.
(soft pop music)
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
(Alana speaks in Welsh)
- It's like a...
It's like DVD.
(Alana laughs)
- No, it means yuck, yuck.
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
(soft pop music)
- Okay, so... So, it's okay--
- What's the rule of this one?
Backward?
- It's the other way around,
so we've got it in English.
- Oh, okay.
- Wanna see if you're,
if you know what it is in Welsh.
One of them you should know
because it's one of your lines,
so you should know it.
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
- Is that right?
(Alana speaks in Welsh)
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
Yes, that's one of my lines, isn't it?
- Yeah, it it is one of your lines.
This one's not, but it's on brand for us.
(soft pop music)
(Josh laughs)
- Are you still watching?
(Alana laughs)
Oh no,
I'm not even gonna guess.
(Alana speaks in Welsh)
(Josh speaks in Welsh)
Are you still watching?
Well, they won't answer if
they're not. (Alana laughs)
There you go.
(Alana speaks in Welsh)
- Well, Josh thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- For humoring to me today,
with my silly little Welsh test.
We should get you,
I mean, I know Welsh
isn't cheap as in a thing.
But it should be,
I wish I give it to you.
- It should be
and as soon as you sorted that,
let me know, you know?
- We'll get you the keys to Cardiff.
- That'll be brilliant.
- Yeah?
- Thank you.
Some loved that.
- Good.